Americans love sausage and bacon we
consider it almost a civil right to have
access to abundant you know low-cost
protein supplies some of the same
factors that make the meat supply chain
so efficient and profitable or also
helping fuel devastating outbreaks of a
novel coronavirus and according to the
US as largest supplier that supply chain
is breaking more meat processing plans
in the Midwest are closing and that
could impact our food supply there are
growing concerns about food shortages so
far over 10,000 workers have been
infected or exposed to kovat 19 and at
least 30 have died members are getting
sick and they're dying workers safety
health in this pandemic is really in
crisis an executive order signed by
President Trump declares meat processing
plants as critical infrastructure if the
administration wants to protect the food
chain what they really need to do is to
protect the health and safety of the
workers in that industry if American
consumers are to continue to enjoy cheap
and plentiful meat processing companies
will have to navigate a fragile balance
of safety and supply before we talk
about what's happening inside these
processing plants it's important to
understand their place in the supply
chain for meat in the United States
farmers raise livestock to certain
weight and size measurements so that
they can sell them to meat processors
and at these processing plants factory
workers will often kill the animal break
it down into different cuts and package
it to the end product that is then
transported to both your local grocery
store and other food service areas like
restaurants or catering companies and
it's the efficiency and scale of this
meat production in the United States
that allow prices to be kept so low so
in some processing centers had a slow
down
reduction and in a few cases should
count entirely all of a sudden we have a
big bottleneck of animals with nowhere
to go in some instances we've seen
farmers that have had to start calling
animals because there's just nowhere to
send their pigs we'll end up having to
euthanize either baby pigs or even
market hogs on that in because there's
just simply nowhere to go with them and
that bottleneck in these processing
centers means like grocery stores in
some areas may see a reduced amount of
supply at the same time these stores are
seeing an increase in demand with
restaurants closing and people eating in
more often it instills a lot of fear in
consumers and ultimately in voters to
have that right to affordable low cost
meat threatened but ramping production
back up in these processing plants and
ensuring safe conditions for workers is
challenging for the same reasons that
normally make them so efficient their
size and the speed at which they operate
let's start with their size what we've
seen the corona virus pandemic is kind
of highlight this industry concentration
that's a handful of very very large
companies control the bulk of America's
meat supply so you have Tyson JVs and
carnby all that account for about
two-thirds of America's beef and the
large bulk of it is produced in a few
dozen plants from the late 60s until now
we've seen about a 70 percent decline in
just the number of slaughterhouses that
exist this industry consolidation has
meant that while there are fewer plants
each plant processes far more meat than
ever before and even a single plant shut
down can have an impact on the overall
supply when just one Smithfield plant in
South Dakota shut down it reduced pork
supply in the country by 4 to 5 percent
the other side of their size is just how
many people work in these plants some of
these plants were very large there's
thousands of employees it's just the
nature of this sort of work a lot of
industries obviously rely on automation
and in pork and beef slaughterhouses
it's not really like that you still have
a lot of hands-on labor it can be up to
2,000 workers on a show
they crowd into break rooms they crowded
into locker rooms they all you know
punch in around the same time using the
same clocks it's loud in these
facilities so workers have to get really
close together to hear each other these
plants have workers working
shoulder-to-shoulder in every single
department and that brings us to the
speed of these facilities but now he
probably knows just how closely some of
these workers are to one another the
reason for that is largely to allow the
production line to move faster the more
hands along the line allows the belt to
move at a faster rate and therefore
deliver more meat at the end of the day
and it's really physically demanding
work and the pace of the line goes so
fast that workers rarely have time to go
to the bathroom because their job is
just to get the meat out in order to put
space between the workers they have to
slow down the line speeds in order to
create a safer environment and manage
these you know multiple threats they
have to slow down the line speeds with a
potential for reduced line speeds and
large factories still slowly coming back
on line returning processing to full
capacity may be a difficult task for
some time and between growing pressure
from farmers who have nowhere to take
their livestock and executives warning
of a looming supply shortage the
government stepped in facing fears of a
nationwide meat shortage president Trump
signed an executive order today to keep
processing plants open despite safety
concerns we just worked with the meat
processors they're thrilled and that
whole bottleneck is broken up but labor
groups fear that ramping plants up too
quickly
to mean workers will continue to be put
at risk welcome I've been very clear
that they have been taking steps to
protect workers so they've done things
like increased sanitation space
outbreaks they're offering PPE
protective gear like math we remain
committed to our employees during this
time and we're implementing many changes
to assist our team members we have
enhanced the cleaning and disinfection
of frequently touched objects and
surfaces and we're continuing to stress
the importance of personal hygiene
measuring temperatures as they come
through the door face coverings
breaks expanded room social distancing
all of these are designed to help keep
our workers safe keeping our work is
safe is what will keep our plants
running but currently companies face no
outside enforcement of these safety
measures the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention instead of issuing very
clear guidance and recommendations on
what employers need to do to protect
workers they worded it down so it says
if possible consider this in almost
every sentence so that it doesn't really
give employers any mandates so you know
there's just a lot going on that shields
companies from responsibility pressures
them to keep production up and
disempowers workers you know I am a
meat-eater I I love bacon and breakfast
sausage and and and all of it we have to
we bacon loving consumers and have to
adapt to the near-term reality of you
know some lower volumes of meat higher
costs of meat and we have to be willing
as consumers to accept that we're not
facing severe food shortages right now
what could drive severe food shortages
long term is if we're reckless if the
companies and the management of these
companies is reckless about that health
and well-being of workers
[Music]
you
you